there will be a few serums in this
section and let's prove the first one
the breakpoint sorry first let's define
the notions of a justices and
breakpoints looking at this permutation
plus 3 and plus 4 are arranged in the
right order in the same order they
arranged inside empty permutation let's
call it an adjacency plus 4 and plus 5
the same story plus 5 and minus 12 is
definitely out of order
and certainly there should be a
breakpoint that cuts between them so
there should be a reversal with one of
its endpoints between plus 5 and minus
12 because otherwise we will never be
able to transform the experimentation
into the NT permutation minus 12 minus 8
also breakpoint this is an interesting
case minus 8 and minus 7
it's not plus 7 and plus 8 as we want to
see in the identity permutation but
maybe there will be a reversal that
contains both minus 8 and minus 7 and
then after reversing they will turn into
perfect orientation and will correspond
to the case +7 + +8 and that's why we
say minus 8 and minus 7 I know that
despite being converted minus 7 minus 6
the same story minus 6 plus 1 is
definitely a breakpoint adjacency
breakpoint this is also a breakpoint
think about why it is a breakpoint again
break point breakpoint and finally a
Justin see I've done not quite yet
because there are two more implicit
elements of this permutation zero and n
plus 1 that describes the start and end
of this permutation and zero and class
three is the break point because zero
should not be next to plus rate should
be next to plus 1 and plus 15 plus 15 is
adjustments so after we define a
justices and breakpoints clearly
number of Justices plus number of
breakpoints in the permutation equals
two lengths of the permutation plus 1
and before we go further I want to ask
you the question what is the number of
breakpoints in the identity permutation
plus 1 plus 2 plus n of course this
permutation has no breakpoints 0 which
means that sorting by reversal is
essentially breakpoint elimination let's
see how it works so let's start from the
initial permutation that has 6
breakpoint we move next there are only 4
breakpoints left we move left again for
breakpoints left we move further to
breakpoints and finally in the identity
permutation 0 breakpoints which means
that every sorting by reversal should
reduce the number of breakpoints from 6
to 0 in this case we don't know what
sequence of reversal is a minimal but we
know that any of each of them will
result in reduction of the number of
breakpoints to 0 next question how many
breakpoints can be eliminated by a
single reversal well the answer to this
question is simple reversal has two ends
and nothing happens with breakpoints on
the left and on the right of this end
points also every breakpoints that
existed vision this interval will
remains the breakpoint and therefore the
only breakpoints then can be affected by
reversals as two break points on the end
of the reversal and since at every step
the number of breakpoints can be reduced
by at most 2 we have the breakpoints
arrium reversal distance should be
larger equal than the number of
breakpoints over 2 and it also
immediately suggests in you greedy
algorithm probably better greedy
algorithm by reversal in the
so only simply need to do to sort a
permutation optimally is to reduce the
number of breakpoints by two at every
step let's look at our sequence of
sorting by reversals and we see that at
this step we did something silly we were
supposed to be reducing the number of
breakpoints
but the number and by two at every step
but the number of breakpoints actually
has not even reduced at this reversal
maybe we should have chosen another
reversal that would reduce the number of
breakpoints by two but you can check
that there is no such rivers and in fact
the rapaera mutation for which there are
no reversal reducing number of
breakpoints even by one which means
whatever you do the number of
breakpoints remains the same and that's
why it turned out that the algorithm by
reversals actually quite complex even if
I had an hour or two of time one-on-one
with you I wouldn't be able to explain
all intricacies of the polynomial
algorithm by reversals and that's why I
will switch from the problem of sorting
by reversal to a different seemingly
even more difficult problem of finding
rearrangements and optimal sorting by of
multi chromosomal genomes